if there are shenanigans going on
perhaps people
perhaps the people involved in that
should have built themselves a
wider margin of error maybe they
couldn't maybe they're just rubbing our
faces in it who knows we do know that
big tech
is censoring president trump they
immediately did this
big technology censoring the president
of the united states
on election night as far as i'm
concerned
so i know that phrase is uh
controversial now but as far as i'm
concerned
the government can break up twitter
twitter is has committed a fraud
they've committed a fraud on how people
use that
platform had they gained the control of
the public square
and our public discourse right you
thought you were getting one thing you
were getting another you thought you
were getting
a an open platform where you could
follow people and actually get their
tweets and say what you want to say
and then you got something else more
akin to a publisher which brings us into
another fraud they're getting liability
protection
through section 230 the communications
decency act shouldn't be getting that
and though twitter i don't think has a
monopoly big tech generally has a
monopoly on information
break it up break it up i don't want to
hear any
ridiculous frivolous arguments about how
it's a private company well
sort of private companies aren't allowed
to commit fraud first of all they're not
allowed to get
uh liability protection that they're
they're not deserving of that they that
they are not
abiding by the rules of but as a broader
political issue
this system is crumbling
the legacy media has completely
declined itself the pollsters are done
there is no reason to listen to these
pollsters again but
certain vestiges of it remain namely big
tech
big tech still has a lot of power
and we're checking these numbers even as
they come in
you've got to break that up you've got
to break up these big technology
companies
what they censored here is that
president trump
said we are up big but they're trying to
steal the election we will never let
them do it votes cannot be cast after
the polls are closed
i said summer all of this content shared
in this tweet is disputed and yep
disputed by twitter
because they're upset because they don't
want to be found out might be misleading
about an election or other civic process
hillary clinton said one of the leaders
of the democratic party said
biden shouldn't concede under any
circumstances elected officials
said joe biden won before election day
is that not that's not sufficient
evidence that some
people in this country are trying to
steal the election obviously some people
i'm not saying everybody's trying to
steal the election i'm not saying that
the election is going to be stolen i'm
not saying that either
but some people are trying to do it
which trump said 100 right doesn't
matter they're going to censor him for
it
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts